choosing a new ipad to buy has never
been more difficult
especially since we just got the brand
new m1
ipad pro which is incredibly powerful
but also very expensive
so what i'm gonna do in this video is
show you guys all the differences
between all of the ipads to help you
decide which one to buy
for your specific use case so as you can
see i've got every single ipad from
apple's current ipad lineup
including the 10.2 inch budget ipad for
329.
the ipad mini 5 for 399
the ipad air 4 for 600.
the 11 inch m1 ipad pro for 800.
and the 12.9 inch mini led
m1 ipad pro for eleven hundred dollars
so let's get right into it comparing the
designs the air and the pros are the
only ones with apple's new
modern flat back inside design language
making them look a whole lot better
compared to the regular ipad
and the ipad mini which are still using
the old chamfered edge design
on top of that they both feature an
older single 8 megapixel camera design
while the air gets a larger 12 megapixel
camera that sticks
out and the ipad pro adds an extra 10
megapixel
ultra wide camera a flash and a lidar
scanner
used for augmented reality apps all
packed into a premium looking
squarish camera bump and another thing
you'll notice on both the air and the
pro
is the smart connector on the back which
is used to connect
accessories like the magic keyboard case
which by itself
makes these more expensive ipads more
desirable meanwhile the budget ipad
houses the older version of the smart
connector on the side
and the mini doesn't have it at all
since it's too small to support a nice
keyboard case
both the air and the pro have a wireless
magnetic connector on the side
for the 2nd gen apple pencil which by
the way
is many times better than the original
because of the new charging design
and the double tap to switch tools
feature the mini and the budget ipad
both
only support the original apple pencil
which charges using the lightning port
on both of those ipads while the air and
the pro
have a usbc port which is much nicer
because it supports a wide range of
accessories
like ipad docks and things like that but
going even further
the new m1 ipad pro actually supports
the high bandwidth thunderbolt port
that usually comes on apple's max
meaning that it can support a wide range
of thunderbolt accessories
like high speed ssds and docks the only
downside with both the air and the pro
is that they unfortunately do not have a
headphone jack
now as far as the speakers both the
budget ipad and the mini
only have speakers on the bottom while
the air and the pro
have speaker grilles on the top as well
the only difference is that the pro has
quad speakers while the air only has
dual stereo speakers
one on the top and one on the bottom
meaning that two of the grilles
are really only there for the looks so
with that said let's jump
right into our speaker comparison so you
can hear the differences for yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
as you've just heard the budget ipad in
the mini don't sound that great
because the audio is only coming from
one side
compared to both sides on the more
expensive ipads
where the 11 inch ipad pro definitely
sounds better
and louder and the 12.9 inch model
is surprisingly quite a bit better now
moving over to the front of the ipads
the less expensive ones feature the old
home button with touch id design
which gives you a square display that
doesn't really look that premium anymore
the air also gets touch id but it's
built into the power button at the top
while the ipad pro features face id
which i would say is absolutely the most
convenient way to authenticate and
unlock your ipad
since it happens automatically without
having to reach for the touch id button
the two more expensive models now
feature the new rounded corner edge to
edge display
with black bezels which definitely looks
more modern and is quite a bit more
immersive
and with that now let's get into the
detailed display comparison
starting with the sizes and in my
opinion
the mini is perfect for kids but not for
most adults
while the 11 inch ipad pro and the air
are perfect for a portable tablet and
the
12.9 inch display is massive
being great for being a laptop
replacement now one notable difference
between them is the brightness
where both of the ipad pros have 600
nits instead of 500 on the
less expensive ipads and this basically
allows the pros
to watch hdr videos on youtube but only
the 12.9 inch ipad pro with the mini led
display
gets true hdr with up to 600 nits of
brightness
since it's packed with over 10 000 mini
leds
with local dimming which means that the
areas of the screen that are completely
black
aren't being lit up at all compared to
the rest of the ipads with standard lcd
displays
that have to light up the entire panel
at once
which leads to very gray blacks as you
can see right here so from a display
quality standpoint
the mini led display is definitely the
best giving you the best picture quality
out of the bunch
but it can have some issues with
blooming when in a dark room
where you'll see a grayish glow around
very bright icons and visuals
but i'd say that it's definitely worth
that drawback now on the other hand
the budget ipad has arguably the worst
display
for a few different reasons first off it
doesn't come with an anti-reflectivity
coating
so you can more easily notice
reflections second it doesn't support
true tone technology
which automatically adjusts the color
balance of the display to keep it
looking paper white
in any environment third it doesn't
support p3 wide color gamut
which basically makes it not as color
accurate as the rest of the
ipads and finally number four its
display
is not laminated which means that there
is a gap in between the actual display
and the glass
leading to a sort of hollow feel when
you tap on it and it makes the apple
pencil experience
not as good or accurate because of that
gap but on the other ipads they feel
very solid and there's no gap visible
while using the apple pencil and on the
ipad pros
the pencil experience is by far the best
because of the extremely low
9 milliseconds latency and that is all
due to the 120 hertz refresh rate pro
motion technology
that's exclusive to the ipad pros which
makes the user experience
super smooth and fluid when scrolling
through webpages or playing games that
support 120fps
compared to the other ipads which only
have a 60hz refresh rate
which feels arguably less smooth now
before i get into performance i want to
cover
the cameras as i've said before the pros
are the only ones with an ultra wide
camera on the back
giving you a wider perspective but this
year
the selfie camera on the pros have been
upgraded to a 12 megapixel ultrawide
camera as well
and it uses the new center stage feature
to automatically center your face as you
move around
which is awesome so with that said
here's a facetime video comparison
so you can hear the differences in the
microphone quality
this right here is the microphone
quality on the budget 10.2 inch ipad
this is the microphone quality on the
ipad mini 5.
this is the microphone quality on the
ipad air 4.
and this is the microphone quality on
the m1 ipad pro now moving on to
performance
both the budget ipad and the mini get
the a12 chip
while the air gets the a14 and the pros
get the new
m1 chip so i'm just going to be showing
the 11 inch model
for these tests as far as the ram the
least expensive ipads get three
gigabytes
the air gets four gigabytes and the pros
get eight gigabytes with the option of a
massive 16 gigs
if you get at least one terabyte of
storage which is very expensive
starting off with geekbench 5 both the
air and the pro have quite a bit more
single core performance
compared to the others which will make
everyday use more snappy so if we look
at web browsing performance both of
those more expensive ipads are basically
twice
as fast which is going to be a huge deal
for those people
who are always on the web on top of that
the ssd storage
read speeds on the air and the pro are
significantly faster than the others
which will make
everyday use and opening apps much
quicker and snappier
compared to the budget ipad and the mini
but perhaps the biggest difference
is in the write speeds which basically
affects transferring files
to the ipad where we see almost three to
four times faster speeds on the air
compared to the less expensive ipads and
an insane
1500 megabytes per second on the pros
likely due to having to support
thunderbolt now moving on to the
multi-core performance
this is where it gets insane with the
pros being basically three times
faster than the cheaper ipads and 70
faster than the air and in terms of
graphics performance
the pros are now around four times
faster than the cheaper ipads
and around 73 percent faster than the
ipad air
now moving on to the more realistic
3dmark wildlife benchmark
we see basically the same differences as
in geekbench except that the air isn't
performing
as well in this comparison so with all
of that said i do want to mention that
the absolutely insane performance
of the m1 ipad pro is overkill for right
now
since even the air can handle basically
every app currently out there
and even the 812 ipads can run a lot of
the apps out there
just fine now moving on to some spec
differences the budget ipad gets
bluetooth 4.2
compared to 5.0 on the rest of the ipads
and both the air and the pro get wi-fi
six but only the pros have the option
for 5g
cellular connectivity if you pay extra
for it they all have the same 10 hours
of rated battery life
but the budget ipad comes with only 32
gigs of storage at the base price
compared to 64 on the mini and the air
and a much nicer 128 gigs on the pros
which can go all the way up to a huge 2
terabytes of storage
so with all of that said let's get right
into my purchasing recommendations
first off i would not recommend anyone
to buy the ipad air 4 right now
because it's only 200 less expensive
than the ipad pro
and it's lacking a ton of features
including the 120hz display
the quad speakers the 600 nits of
brightness for hdr video support
the extra cameras on the back including
the flash and the lidar scanner
the much better 12 megapixel selfie
camera the better studio quality
microphones
optional 5g connectivity the thunderbolt
port
the extra 4 gigabytes of ram and 64 gigs
of storage at the base price
and of course the massive difference in
performance so based on all of that
the ipad pro is a no-brainer compared to
the air
so either buy the pro or go for one of
the less
expensive ipad models do not buy the
ipad air
now if you want a basic ipad but you're
on a budget i'd say that the 10.2 inch
ipad is a
great choice since you get the same a12
chip as the ipad mini
for a lower 329 price and you also get
the smart connector
so you can add on a keyboard case like
the logitech combo touch
to turn it into a budget laptop
replacement and that
a12 chip should be just fine for a lot
of the games and apps on the app store
so you don't really have to worry about
that now on the other hand the ipad mini
for 400
gets the laminated display which is
definitely nicer
but the display size is so small that i
wouldn't really recommend it for gaming
or for adults
i would really only recommend the
current mini for small children
who can't handle a larger ipad that well
and of course there's the new ipad pros
starting at 800 which i would recommend
for anyone who's willing to invest the
extra cash
to make sure they're getting a totally
future-proofed ipad
that can handle anything they throw at
it for the next few years
especially since the design has already
been updated and it's got the new
thunderbolt port and as far as the 12.9
inch ipad pro for eleven hundred dollars
this is meant for the real professionals
out there who want to use it for work
or professional editing or simply anyone
who really cares about having
the best display out there thanks to the
new mini led tech
or maybe you just like having the
massive display size
so with all of that said here's my final
verdict on which ipad you should buy in
2021
either go for the 329 ipad if you're on
a budget
or go straight to the 800 m1 ipad pro
if you're willing to invest the extra
cash to make sure that it's future-proof
hopefully this video helped to make a
decision and if it did
use those links below to order your new
ipad but if you're still confused on
which one to buy
comment your specific situation down
below and i'd be happy to help
if you enjoyed this video click that
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you
in the next video